how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel
all things mcu and spider-man 3.
things just keep ramping up with this
movie
things get more and more exciting each
day and more and more people are
returning
for this movie the spider-man 3 giant
multiverse event is basically 95
confirmed at this point with jamie
foxx's electro officially returning
alfred molina officially returning as dr
octopus
and of course many different reports
from many different sources stating that
toby mcguire
andrew garfield kirsten dunst and emma
stone are returning as well
and now two new people to add to the
list of returning characters from
different universes
today we have reports that norman
osborne is going to be in the marvel
cinematic universe but
this norman osborne will be coming from
the sam raimi universe as it's reported
that willem dafoe will reprise his role
as norman osborne aka the green goblin
in spider-man 3.
and it looks like he's going to be
bringing with him the sandman
the same report states that thomas
hayden church will be reprising his role
as the sandman
and will be appearing in spider-man
homecoming 3 as well so we'll break down
this report and talk about what these
villains returning means
for spider-man 3. if you're new be sure
to subscribe to stay up to date on all
the latest spider-man 3 news and mcu
news and so you can enter my giveaway
for a chance to win a tony stark quantum
suit funko pop provided by heroes
hideout.com i'll be picking a winner
this friday
so we've actually heard many reports
that norman osborne and ozcorp are going
to be in spider-man 3
but perhaps we were wrong about which
version is going to actually be in the
movie
as we have a report from the
illuminati.com stating that marvel
studios is
in full pursuit of willem dafoe and is
working out the final deal with him
right now to return as norman osborne in
spider-man homecoming 3.
and again according to the illuminati
the same deal is being worked out right
now with thomas hayden church to return
as the sandman
so peter parker or the peter parkers are
going to have their hands full in
spider-man 3 but what does this mean
that some of these characters are
returning
the fact that sam raimi's norman osborne
and dr octopus
jamie foxx's elektro and emma stone from
the amazing spider-man universe are all
coming back as reported and rumored to
come back
means that not only are multiverses
colliding but they are colliding at
different points in time
because all these actors and actresses
are dead in their respective universes
this means that the universes are going
to be colliding at different points in
time
in their universes or perhaps the mcu is
going to do
a little bit of retconning to their
respective universes my guess is that
the universes are going to be colliding
at different points in time
i don't actually think that doctor
strange is going to open up a portal to
a different universe and grab these
people out i think that the universes
are kind of starting to fuse together
and collide and when they all collide
they'll be at different times this is
how
dr octopus the green goblin electro and
gwen stacy can all be alive
or perhaps doctor strange managed to
bring back the time stone and he'll work
some time travel magic
but with this news comes a very big
question and that is
is there actually going to be a main mcu
timeline
norman osborne we know that the old
avengers tower has been bought by
someone and there have been many reports
of an actual norman osborn popping up
and that building being oscorp
however the fantastic four are coming in
2023 so that tower could go on to be the
baxter building
it's possible but at this point
spider-man obviously has more of a
connection to ozcorp and the green
goblin over the fantastic four
and we know and have heard from some
outlets that spider-man isn't leaving
the mcu anytime soon
in fact he's probably going to have
three more films especially since
spider-man 3 is a multiverse film it's
going to blow up
and it'll probably beat avengers in game
if it is a true multiverse film with
three different spider-man in it
so setting up an actual oz corp in our
main world
makes perfect sense and it gives us a
major villain not only in the spider-man
universe but in the main mcu as well
and that is because the dark avengers
have been rumored to come and
osborne in the comics leads the dark
avengers in
an iron man suit so this could set up a
lot for the future
of the mcu it could be osborne but until
then it looks like we're getting sam
raimi's osborne coming back and also
sandman
the list keeps getting bigger and bigger
so let me know what you think about this
news and how excited you are for
spider-man 3 in the comments down below
don't forget to follow me on instagram
and twitter for funny memes and
live updates and as always thank you all
so much for watching
woof